i do not understand
does the rasa cannot have enough of its
own people
look around sir things are heating up in
the city
suits no one sparks all it takes for
japan town to go up in flames
riots are always best put down by folks
not spoiling your brand name
ah you are here
thank you good to see you
as it is to see you pee
i acquired some information of my own
do you know for most wish to honor
arasaka
with the parade
doesn't seem like the kind you care to
honor tradition
that is so japanese heritage is one
element
yorinobu will also put on a display of
power
the floats are sure to be beautiful but
the wise and
i will see in there my hidden message to
his force
what message would that be i am here
watch your backs not one for subtlety is
he
still don't see how this gets us
anywhere
i have had an idea look to the sky
the dash floats will pass precisely this
way
if i could just get onto hanako sama's
afloat
i could speak with her in private get
there how
why jump of course
expectations way too high goro couldn't
pull that off even if you still had your
fancy implants
i have thought of a solution while you
are occupied with your shady dealings
i learned more about the floats they are
all kept in one place
arasaka industrial park it is there that
they prepare them
we need only to break into the compound
find the right float
and inject a virus into its system
you will then be able to disable any
security before i
sneak inside
lots of ways to skin this particular cat
gonna need i know what you need
it is taking care of i have an infected
shard it was not cheap but the man
who sold it to me guaranteed it will
work
would you get this short across the
canal
kabuki i'd actually be half decent soft
then
and if it isn't got a few tricks up my
sleeve too
this is good to know
let us move on
to take control of the float is one
thing but not all
the security concerns me the snipers
especially
i will be an easy target but i may have
an answer
okada mentioned the city camera
if we gain access to them we will see
exactly where the snipers are
you can deal with their messiah depends
sounds like a plan you agree just like
that
the risks are considerable yeah well
get more and more used to that and now
what would you say to a small test we
must try the shard
the camera control room is in front of
us
you must get inside and infect the
network that is all
uh-huh and in the meantime you'll do
what crack open a can of suds
i will not touch alcohol at work
i will watch your back now get to it
feet
[ __ ] worked
and
done systems ours the shot works
good the easy work we have done
to break into arasaka industrial park
will not be such a bit of roses
but before we discuss that
sit i have not eaten since yesterday
give me the best on the menu
i highly recommend the yakitori today
anything that isn't local please
merle
i can't believe i'm saying this but this
soccer scum might actually prove useful
he's a well-trained dog needs orders
that's all
and when he outlives his purpose we'll
flatline him
he's not on his a-game sure even without
implants he could decommission
easily where's that coming from ever
seen him in action
no just know the way he walks
look in his eye we'll come back to this
later
what is this
okay i have laid the plan
one we break into arasaka industrial
park
one and a half we have kahanakosama's
float
two during the parade with my help
you eliminate any snipers
three i get onto the float
four i convince hanakosama of the truth
well sounds like a suicide run but done
dumb as [ __ ] than this so
things are even more stupid than
stealing from arasaka
none dumber yet no set the bar pretty
high with that one now
we part reconnaissance is required
what are you doing don't let him off his
leash let him stranger in a strange land
i'm going with you
true and you with your hands
skills mind of a thief
agreed this we will do together
cook louder louder
i have decided to double him out of our
acting
city security forces president myers
was that not a provocation was that
another
arasaka an empire built to last
before your enough set fire to it from
the inside
all of this began with him
the factions power struggles
all of this so
why'd saburo tolerate it all can't get
my head around it but kept his son on a
short leash
arasaka was a strong and disciplined man
the strongest man i have ever known
and yet at a critical moment
he showed a weakness for your noble
for his daughter when urinal performed
his band of
hounds declared war on his
own family arasakasana could have
crushed him with
one word yet he did not
for he did not wish his daughter to
suffer
when you're in a return his tail between
his legs
she persuaded her father to give him a
second chance
do you understand anakosama saved urine
up from the consequences of
his deeds
feels like that's about to change as
long as we get hanukkah to believe
our version of events conscience could
also come into play
assuming she's got one we must reach her
first
will you join me
sure why not let us go from here
i hope you enjoyed it please come again
so dustin plastic
come i have found a good
[Music]
place to observe
we must just climb up here
now this way
fortune smiles to us it seems no one is
here today
[Music]
[Music]
continues
do not enter pacifica
i would call this a beautiful view of
the city
hate night city that much
perhaps i am simply homesick as you say
now you must look for vulnerabilities
weaknesses while i try to think of a
diversion
arasaka cannot discover our intentions
a bit of sabotage it's just what we need
to divert
their attentions you will have the best
view on the left
i will try here this old scope should be
good for something
shall we begin
let's do this
there's no time to waste me
got eyes on the calm system a lot of
guards
i could use combs for a diversion
camouflage tourists by the gate a last
result
i do not wish to die there
footbridge but it's gorgeous
transformer by the wall see it we should
use it to step
up this is not bad
i think i've seen everything you wish to
come for this reconnaissance
do your job i expected you to be more
useful than this
all right quit moaning i'll give it
another glance
pipes see them we could use them to get
inside
[Music]
antenna security hub's liable to be in
that building
perfect for sabotage
[Music]
looks like a service tunnel by the road
there it could lead to the warehouses
[Music]
trucks drive up regularly
armored door seal tight
[Music]
i think i've seen everything we have
what we came for
so we going in
it is what you said before entering a
competition
i wish to be certain we have not
overlooked anything
we should wait and observe if nothing
out of the ordinary happens
then yes we're in then sounds sensible
better get comfy
fee what
no sudden movements do you see it
that yet
so it's cow like any other
it is the first animal i see in night
city
except cockroaches of course first it
was birds
then dogs cats actually put up a fight
longest
perhaps it is a back a nickel
back in echo what's that it is a cat's
spirit
it brings misfortune can restore the
dead back to life
feline ghost suppose anything's possible
[Music]
my grandmother knew many many stories
about
kitsune kappa bakeneko too
miss home a foolish
question
i am from the slums of chiva 11.
once when i was desperate to live there
i
[Music]
bad memories washed away by time i
long only for the simple days of
childhood
childhood memories let's see
hopping buildings running away from
badges
iron taste of blood from a split lip
[Music]
i remember the chemical stench of the
canal
where we boys washed our shirts
corporate transporters sometimes passed
through our slum
arasaka selecting children but
only the clean ones
let me guess so they could turn them
into corvo soldiers
exactly when they chose me
i felt i had won the lottery
in the army i was given everything i
lacked before disciplining regular meals
and when i proved i was gifted
an education
did what you had to to keep from going
hungry
i sense that you judge me and yet
you have no right to unlike you and
your friend mr wells i was not arrowhead
i did not take the easy path
[Music]
wasn't judging you and true you opposed
the corporations
their order their world in a mindless
way
yet you offer no wealthy alternative
take a look around it's here your
corporate world and its glorious
splendor
you show me filthy streets as if no
other world exists
as if nothing else is possible what of
the millions who work for arasaka and
receive stability save shiva 11 slum
rats
they're there scraping scraps out of
scoptines
corpse decided that too
we cannot fix everything at once
you already forget what happened to
tom's diner people hate corpse more than
anything
can't blame him either got some regrets
but clapping from arasaka
ain't one of them
sometimes i wish to become a nomad to
leave this world
forget everything
[Music]
never too late to change
what is your expression one cannot teach
an
old dog new tricks
[Music]
do you know what i think what's that
that day in competing we both have lost
someone important and we are not at
peace with this
so we seek conflict argue eagerly
finally start to make some sense
there's one thing you should know it is
about
mr wales about jack
what is it
[Music]
when i set out to find you others went
to find
jackie they took his body the life of me
can't figure why
so his mom couldn't give him a proper
send-off
arasaka has a method for playing the
information from the dead
what are you talking about don't ask for
details i understand little i know they
use the soul killer program to do so
they can pull an engram from well's body
damaged incomplete but still an
engram [ __ ] evil
jackie's psyche where are they keeping
it this
i do not know why am i only hearing this
now
i did not know i could trust you the
circumstances have changed
back in echo got sick of us looks like
it will find its own way
[Music]
i think it is time to do something
oh [ __ ] get morse you do not
look so bad
foreign
so
hmm i'll be
in touch
[Music]
so
and
good
i'm in good now try to enter the
warehouse
i will draw their attention away
so
foreign
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
you you really what
did i drop them
truly bad
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
come out with your hands in the air
[Music]
soldier kia
[Music]
hmm
come out with your hands in the air
[Music]
uh
uh
[Music]
it could be an ordinary terminal gotcha
how's things at urant
good i reached the contour room
and make a terrible mess very well
i am ready when you finish
up i will personally find you and bury
you
both starts to do it as we please fly to
tokyo if you want
i just may do that good work now
it is my turn can you see terrible kills
even the room is slowly me
that is your will your building
smaller ones use them to come down
ourselves with patience
i will contact you before the parade
until then
try not to get into any more trouble
as if i wasn't in enough already